[Musique]
elles ont survécu à l'enfer sauvé des
eaux par l'équipe de sos méditerranée
ces femmes sont mises à l'écart à bord
de l'aquarium aux médecins sans
frontières il s'agit de les protéger car
elles sont considérées extrêmement
vulnérable et une échelle inédite
on va beaucoup de cas de violence
sexuelle en droit des femmes qui ont été
exemplaires vendus pourra faire des
sales [ __ ]
des actes sexuels avec un des hommes
inconnus qu'est ce que tous ont été
violées en libye traités comme des
esclaves forcées de se prostituer et
sont des femmes jeunes qui voyagent
seuls et qui voyagent en groupe ça c'est
déjà une situation un qui nous met
dedans dans la lettre
mais alors que ces femmes s'apprêtent à
débarquer en italie leur cauchemar n'est
pas terminé pour autant
un danger bien réel les guettent encore
l'exploitation sexuelle selon
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations
80% des nigérianes arrivée par la
méditerranée en italie sont exploités
par des réseaux de proxénètes et
finissent ici sur le bord d'une route à
vendre leur corps
le l'entité nationale près de catane en
sicile
des dizaines de femmes tentent d'attirer
l'attention des automobilistes pour leur
offrir du sexe à bon marché des passes
rapides payé presque rien daniel par
exemple affirme ne jamais gagner plus de
50 à 60 euros par jeu à tort pour le
travail qu'elle ne fait pas par plaisir
tient elle à préciser
car personne on aime ce travail elle dit
cependant n'avoir pas d'autre choix pour
nourrir ses deux enfants restés au
nigeria loin
blessing 23 ans avoue détester et nous
si ce qu'elle est devenue
forcés de travailler comme les autres
filles pendant de longues heures sans
repos martel comme des robots
ces femmes sont nigériane toutes
viennent de la même région de bénin city
beaucoup se sont fait promettre un bon
travail en europe comme coiffeuse ou
femme de ménage se souvient encore des
promesses qu'on lui a fait ils m'ont dit
que j'allais vivre mieux que j'allais
être heureuse et livres angie est parti
à 17 ans du nigeria mais pas parfois une
nébuleuse histoire de dette à rembourser
la contrainte et larmes première des
trafiquants les menaces contre les
proches
la magie noire aussi et des sortilèges
en cas de désobéissance avant quitté
nigeria il vous faut jurer que vous
allez obéir sinon vous allez subir une
malédiction explique-t-elle et nous
sommes décidés mezriche for ever
torturé forcées de se prostituer pendant
cinq mois en libye
angie a finalement réussi à s'enfuir
réfugié en italie
elle va maintenant à l'école et rêve
d'un avenir meilleur avec sa petite
fille qu'elle appelait purity pureté
dans son malheur andy a eu la chance de
trouver de l'aide sur sa route hébergés
dans ce centre d'accueil protéger des
réseaux de proxénètes un cas isolé car
la plupart du temps selon la
coordonnatrice du centre les victimes de
trafic humain sont laissées à
elles-mêmes ont besoin d'être elle ne
mérite pas finir dans la rue d'être
exploités et maltraités
elles ont besoin qu'on leur donne une
deuxième chance nous parler c'est pour
lancer un message aux jeunes femmes
d'afrique de l'ouest
tenté par le rêve européen c'est
comorienne
si ça va détruire votre vie votre avenir
c'est vraiment pas une bonne idée vous
le déconseille fortement selon louis ix
ème 11000 nigérianes sont arrivés en
italien en 2016 une hausse de 600 % par
rapport aux années précédentes
toutes sont a priori considérés comme
des victimes potentielles exploitation
sexuelle
[Musique]